okay this morning I was browsing the
David Pakman show subreddit it's a place
where you can hang out with over five
thousand David Pakman show viewers and
listeners david pakman.com slash read it
a lot of very interesting discussions
including one about a recent article
that was written about dave rubin the
political chameleon which actually
references me there's this article
that's been written i forget where but i
tweeted it a few days ago and it is
called dave rubin a political chameleon
and it points out that dave rubin once
was interviewed by david pakman not that
long ago and that i gave some very
significant pushback to some of Rubens
ideas and the article alleges that it
didn't go particularly well for dave
rubin really this is not my telling of
it this is this journalists telling of
it and a discussion going on about that
on our subreddit very very interesting
also on the david pakman show subreddit
a new liberal talking point has been
suggested and it is to call republicans
soft on taxes the idea that if you're
all about tax breaks for the rich and
tax breaks for corporations and cutting
estate taxes and all of this nonsense
that you should be branded by the left
as being soft on taxes the way the right
likes to talk about people being soft on
crime or soft on terror i think it's a
very interesting idea i just don't know
that it'll work i think that republicans
can pretty easily spend their way out of
it's very tough for liberals to talk
about taxes and argue if like
effectively on the topic yeah and just
boiling it down to those simple terms it
sounds like a good idea but i don't know
if it would work in practice i think it
would be tough in practice but i like
that people are thinking about this
stuff on the david pakman show subreddit
also from the david pakman show
subreddit fox news hey David do you
watch fox news do you ever watch fox
news have you been recently it's
complete and utter unhinged Matt madness
is it even worth your time to point out
their bias and delusion or do you assume
most of your viewers already know this I
have talked about this a little bit I
used to try to catch like five or ten
minutes of each cable news channel a day
at different times of day just to see
what's going on I basically don't do
that anymore because it is impossible at
this point to watch Fox News it's
mind-numbing ly stupid and I now realize
when people call in and they go listen
my mom my dad my uncle they've been
sucked in by Fox News and they just have
a worldview that doesn't even at all
align with what we consider the
empirical realities of our planet and if
you just put on five minutes of Fox News
it is a fantasy world yeah completely
and now with Bill O'Reilly gone with
megyn kelly gone bowling gone it's not
the same I'm entertained no it's not
it's watching Greg Gutfeld is not the
same as when you used to be able to
watch Bill O'Reilly's thinly-veiled
racially tinged attacks on non-white
Americans for example those were the old
days and now you've got to watch Bill
O'Reilly sitting in his Long Island home
doing the interviews with very very
minor online right-wing media entities
it's it's how far he's fallen it's sad
and lastly from our reddit discussion
forum Hackman's Boehner on today's show
yeah I had a Freudian slip on I think it
was Monday or Tuesday where I was
reading a tweet and I instead of saying
John Boehner I started to say John
Boehner yeah and a lot of people picked
up on it and someone even developed a
funny little comic pant comic strip
panel and put it on our subreddit but
yeah a lot of people reacting to my
Freudian slip one could say that Boehner
just came out of your mouth yes and Tom
Hartman used to not jokingly just call
him John Boehner he would just
deliberately call him John Boehner it
wasn't a Freudian slip he just thought
it was funny to call him John Boehner
and maybe I picked that up somehow or
something like that but it's not
deliberate it was not deliberate that I
can assure you david pakman.com slash
read it that's where you can sign up and
is someone trying to break down our door
yeah I don't know if that's picking up
on yeah I'm not sure if the mics picked
that up but sometimes while we're taping
it's just urgent that someone get in
here for some reason and they start
trying to break down the door but we
will not relent we will continue with
the David Pakman show